vielen dank also die haushaltswoche
immer gleich aufgebaut von dienstag bis
freitag und der mittwochmorgen das ist
der tag wo es zur generaldebatte kommt
der oppositionschef wird hier gleich um
9 uhr beginnen darauf dann der kanzler
antworten obwohl ich auch schon mal
erlebt habe aber das ist lange lange her
zu bonner zeiten dass bundeskanzler
helmut kohl sich über den damaligen
oppositionschef so aufgeregt hat dass er
erst in der sozusagen nächsten runde
gesprochen hat was wiederum seine
presseleute nicht so glücklich stimmte
weil damit der kanzler erst gegen mittag
redete und das natürlich für die
agenturen da nicht so toll war aber das
wird olaf scholz heute nicht machen also
er wird als zweiter reden und natürlich
geht es in dieser generaldebatte oben
die bilanz der letzten monate der neuen
bundesregierung der ampel regierung aber
vor allen dingen natürlich auch um die
rückschau auf diese große rede von olaf
scholz zeitenwende hat er gesagt das war
am 27 februar und hat das hunderte
milliarden sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr angekündigt am wochenende gab
es da eine einigung zwischen den ampel
fraktionen und der cdu/csu den man
braucht eine zweidrittelmehrheit im
bundestag und bundesrat um das
grundgesetz zu ändern und damit die
bundeswehr eben diese 100 milliarden
ausschöpfen kann seit gestern abend sind
auch zahlen bekannte welche
teilstreitkräfte wie viel geld bekommen
alle darüber möchte ich sprechen mit
meinen beiden gästen heute agnieszka
bürger begrüße ich herzlich die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der bündnisgrünen und florian hahn der
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der cdu
csu bei der generaldebatte erhan ist es
so dass die opposition vorliegen darf
deswegen die erste frage an sie sie
kommen gerade aus dem ausschuss war zu
hören dass die union probleme hat und
die abstimmung die heute morgen im
ausschuss stattfinden sollte über die
verteilung der gelder wohl nochmal
aufhalten will also die union hat keine
probleme sondern es ist schlichtweg so
dass es noch ein paar fragezeichen jetzt
in den details geht gibt insgesamt haben
sie richtig gesagt gab es am wochenende
eine einigung die tatsächlich das paket
aussehen könnte allerdings ist es jetzt
so dass wenn man sich mit den details
beschäftigt und dazu gehört zum beispiel
der wirtschaftsplan das heißt wofür wird
konkret werden die 100 milliarden
ausgegeben hier gibt es erst seit
gestern nachmittag tatsächlich ein
dokument das dem haushaltsausschuss auf
zugegangen ist und somit auch den mit
beratenden gremien wie dem
verteidigungsausschuss und hier sind ein
paar fragezeichen die wollen wir heute
noch klären wir sind wieder komplett die
werden wir mit den beteiligten häusern
und gremien klären und nicht im
fernsehen aber ich bin guter dinge dass
wir insgesamt dieses paket in dieser
woche oder sonst zweifel auch in der
nächsten woche verabschieden können denn
es geht hier um 100 milliarden dafür
werden extra schulden aufgenommen das
ist kann man nicht mit heißer nadel
stricken sondern das muss grundsolide
sein das ist das was die bürgerinnen und
bürger auch erwarten frau becker sie
haben auch die vorlage erst gestern
bekommen wie die aufteilung stattfinden
soll dann haben sie das mit ihren
verteidigungspolitikern durchgesprochen
und keinerlei probleme offensichtlich
bei den grünen ja wir haben sehr
intensiv beraten haben uns jedes projekt
und jede zahl sehr gründlich angeguckt
und konnten dann auch abends eine
rückmeldung geben dass wir mit diesem
wirtschaftsplan so einverstanden sind da
sind ja probleme und projekte die wir
schon seit jahren im
verteidigungsausschuss diskutiert und
deshalb war ich sehr erstaunt zu hören
heute morgen dass die union
offensichtlich nicht sprechen ist dass
sie es nicht geschafft haben obwohl wir
so lange verhandelt haben ihre
fraktionen immer druck gemacht hat es
soll schnell gehen irgendwie eine
konsolidierte antwort zu geben
offensichtlich scheint es da uneinigkeit
zwischen csu und cdu zu geben und
vielleicht hätte herr merz gestern abend
nicht im flieger sitzen soll sondern
sich mal mit dem wirtschaftsplan
beschäftigen müssen per hand 40,9
milliarden sind vorgesehen für die
dimensionen luft heißt das ein bisschen
komisch unter anderem eben die
anschaffung des kampfjets f-35 der ja
auch die nukleare teilhabe deutschlands
sichern soll das ist sicherlich ein
punkt da wenn sie keine probleme haben
also woher also die kenntnis über die
genauen zahlen haben weiß ich nicht will
ich auch nicht bestätigen denn das sind
tatsächlich dokumente die noch nicht
öffentlich sind aber insgesamt ist es
kein geheimnis frau becker hat das ja
auch gerade gesagt natürlich gehört das
thema nukleare teilhabe und deren
aufrechterhaltung zu denen tatsächlich
beschaffungs projekten die schon lange
bekannt sind und die vermutlich eben
dann auch von dem sondervermögen mit
erfasst sind und das ist auch sehr sehr
wichtig weil der tornado tatsächlich an
seine dienstzeit ende kommt und wenn wir
die nukleare teilhabe aufrechterhalten
wollen brauchen wir ein anderes
trägersystemen die f 35 ist dafür
geeignet und wenn das sonderpaket
zusammen mit den grünen mit der spd und
der fdp auf den weg gebracht wird dann
ist das auch ein klares bekenntnis zur
nuklearen teilhabe frau bürger wenn es
probleme gibt bei der opposition in dem
fall der cdu csu ist das eigentlich gut
für die ampel fraktionen denn zumindest
bei der spd stehen ja auch nicht alle
hinter diesem 100 milliarden paket
jessica rosenthal viele linkere jusos
haben gesagt das können wir nicht
mittragen also das kabinett hat
ursprünglich ein sehr guten vorschlag
vorgelegt dann haben wir mit der union
verhandelt sind der union auch
entgegengekommen ich fand den
ursprünglichen entwurf deutlich besser
weil dann auch die frage des schutts im
raum besser abgedeckt gewesen wäre durch
diese mittel und natürlich auch die
gefahr einfach da ist dass es zu einem
cyberangriff kommt aber insofern kann
ich wirklich nicht verstehen dass herr
hahn jetzt gerade sagt dass wir jetzt
vielleicht die verabschiedung nicht mehr
in dieser woche machen sollen wir sind
der union entgegen gekommen die haben da
eigentlich schon eingeschlagen und
deshalb bin ich wirklich sehr erstaunt
über das chaos das heute morgen herrscht
wir sollten schnell entscheiden aus
staatspolitischer verantwortung muss
auch die union jetzt mal in die puschen
kommen heute abend wieder sitzungen der
ausschüsse kann es also sein dass man
sich heute abend dann noch einige oder
würden sie sagen die abstimmung ist
diese woche abgeblasen
nein also das kann auf jeden fall sein
es ist auch noch mal wir sind da auch
absolut willens es geht auch nicht darum
tatsächlich dieses wichtige projekt ist
ja völlig mit dem bundeskanzler einer
meinung dass das notwendig ist und das
wollen wir auch unterstützen überhaupt
gar keine frage da gibt es auch bei uns
in der fraktion überhaupt gar keinen
keinen disput darüber beziehungsweise
keine abweichler wir werden das sehr
geschlossen dann tatsächlich auf den weg
bringen wenn es soweit ist aber noch
einmal 100 milliarden mal ein paar
milliarden hier oder da verschieben das
geht so nicht wir wollen hier klarheit
haben und das wollen wir im laufe des
tages klären bis zur sondersitzung des
verteidigungsausschusses im
haushaltsausschuss heute abend das mit
den milliarden dürfte politiker nicht so
schwer verein sprechen seit der
griechenland krise sind wir es gewohnt
auch über 24 stunden plötzliche
entscheidungen zu treffen frau bürger
wenn wir mal die aufteilung angucken
dieser 100 milliarden da fällt auf wenn
sie mir das mal erklären können 20
sieben jahren für die führungsfähigkeit
der bundeswehr darin digitalisierung und
auch was mit forschung entwicklung gibt
es dann auch noch mit satelliten
kommunikation in der tat hat die
verteidigungsministerin jahr beklagt
dass sie gar nicht an sie denkt sondern
an normale funkgeräte denn bei nato
einsätzen ist es so dass deutsche
soldaten gar nicht mit diesem material
umgehen können also ist das hier schon
ein bisschen ein bisschen zukunftsmusik
die da beschrieben wird mit
krieg in den welten im weltraum nein es
ist keine zukunftsmusik sondern im
gegenteil aus den vergangenen jahren
auch natürlich in der verantwortung der
letzten bundesregierung gibt es
zahlreiche probleme der bundeswehr die
immer wieder verschleppt und verzögert
worden sind gerade im beschaffungs
bereich und das er braucht es jetzt
dieses sondervermögen einerseits
angesichts der extremen
sicherheitspolitischen lage die wir über
den angriffskrieg in der ukraine haben
dass wir mehr für unseren schutz der
bürgerinnen und bürger aber auch unsere
verbündeten tun müssen und andererseits
diese ganzen probleme der letzten jahre
jetzt einmal solide und seriös
aufarbeiten müssen das kann ja nicht
sein dass die bundeswehr
nicht über verschlüsselten funk verfügt
und deshalb nato übung so stattfinden
das ehrlich gesagt russland sie fast
eins zu eins ab die wehr beauftragt hat
vor kurzem ihren bericht vorgelegt und
hat gesagt 77
einsatzfähigkeit der hauptwaffensysteme
das ist reichlich wenig herr hahn wie
kommt das die union hat jahre lang
regiert warum ich die bundeswehr so
schlecht zurecht ja das ist vollkommen
richtig das ist nicht befriedigend und
dann vor allem mit blick auf die
aktuelle krisensituation in europa
ausgelöst durch den krieg den putin
angezettelt hat das liegt natürlich
daran dass wir in den letzten jahren zu
wenig investiert haben die union hätte
das gerne getan das ist am
koalitionspartner vor allem
finanzminister scholz tatsächlich
gescheitert die spd hat sogar wahlkämpfe
bestritten wo sie plakatiert hat die
union möchte zwei prozent erreichen wir
möchten gerne die kostenfreie kita so
war die lage und im übrigen kann ich nur
sagen ich habe die anträge zu den
haushaltsberatungen vergangenen jahren
verteidigungsausschuss habe ich die
anträge der grünen vermisst wo sie
darauf gedrängt hätten wir müssen mehr
investieren in die bundeswehr stolz ist
ein gutes stichwort der bundeskanzler
hat jetzt gestern angekündigt dass man
im ringtausch mit griechenland panzer
liefern wird es gibt ja schon in
slowenien polen diesen ringtausch bisher
hat noch überhaupt nicht stattgefunden
der bundestag hat entschieden schwere
waffen zu liefern bisher hat noch
überhaupt keine waffen die vom
stattgefunden was ist da los es ist ja
nicht so dass keine waffen lieferung
schwerer hoffen gerade in den ersten
wochen ist glaube ich viel auch
geliefert worden was wirklich einen
unterschied gemacht hat und jetzt wird
ja beispielsweise in idar oberstein
einer panzerhaubitze
ausgebildet damit dieses system wenn es
in die ukraine gebracht wird auch
schnell in den einsatz kommen kann
natürlich müssen wir uns jeden tag
fragen was wir tun können um die
waffenlieferung auch zu beschleunigen
und auszuweiten daran arbeiten wir an
der ampel koalition möchte aber nochmal
auf den hinweis von herrn hahn sagen
seit der annexion der krimis oder
verteidigungshaushalt deutlich
angestiegen und das problem ist nicht
nur dass mangelnde geld gewesen sondern
dass man mit unseriösen wahlkreis
wünschen die nicht den
sicherheitspolitischen prioritäten
entsprochen haben unfassbar viel geld in
beschaffung skandalen verbrannt hat ja
und das muss jetzt christine lambrecht
lösen mit der gleichen beschaffungs
würde nämlich in koblenz fast 10.000
beamte sitzen da das scheint nicht zu
funktionieren ihre vorgängerinnen haben
sich ja auch da die zähne ausgebrochen
ausgebissen herr weise der ehemalige
chef der bundesanstalt für arbeit hat
gesagt wir müssen das ganze umbauen in
einer agentur wäre das eine gute idee
das würden wir gerne tun wir haben das
auch als union immer vorgeschlagen auch
das ist im übrigen am koalitionspartner
spd gescheitert einen letzten koalition
ich bin guter hoffnung frau lambrecht
hat sehr ambitionierte ziele ausgegeben
was die in form des
beschaffungsprozesses angeht wir werden
sehen wie die 100 milliarden dann auch
tatsächlich abfließen das ist sozusagen
daran wird er gemessen aber lassen sie
mich noch einen satz sagen zum thema
schwere waffen es gibt allein 150
kampfpanzer leopard 1 die tatsächlich
sofort verfügbar wäre es gäbe
vermutlich mehr als 100
schützenpanzer marder die sofort
verfügbar werden für die ukraine das
sind dinge die aktuell von der
bundesregierung blockiert werden ich
kann das bis heute nicht verstehen wir
könnten viel schneller tatsächlich
wirksame schwere waffen an die ukraine
geben und es liegt auch nicht an den
grünen robert habeck fordert das ja auch
immer anton hofreiter hat gerade gesagt
bis jetzt ist viel zu wenig passiert
freiburger was ist da los können sie
zufrieden sein mit dem verhalten der
sozialdemokraten sage ich jetzt mal in
dem sinne mit dem bundeskanzler der
rücksicht nehmen muss oder schreiben
rücksicht nimmt auf teile seiner
fraktion denn es passiert einfach viel
zu langsam etwas natürlich ist es
wichtig dass solche entscheidungen auch
immer eine abwägung von risiken und
gefahren getroffen werden und ich finde
es erstmal nicht falsch dass eine
regierung sich solche entscheidungen
auch nicht einfach macht das modell ist
ja folgendes dass wir über den
ringtausch
sicherstellen dass verbündete die noch
gerät aus sowjet beständen haben das
schnell in die ukraine bringen können
dafür keine ausbildung erforderlich ist
und wir die anderen entscheidungen jetzt
auf den weg bringen müssen und eben
fragen von instandsetzung munition
ausbildung auch mit klären müssen wie
das bei der panzerhaubitze geschehen ist
aber den ringtausch verstehe ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht weil es wird immer gesagt
die bundeswehr kann keine waffen abgeben
wenn man jetzt an griechenland panzer
liefert dann sind das ja panzer aus den
beständen der bundeswehr da wird immer
gesagt eigentlich geht dass sich die
können wir nicht in die ukraine liefern
da geht es doch nicht nur um die
bedienung sondern auch in der
argumentation auch darum wir sind sonst
nicht für die landesverteidigung
aufgestellt diese panzer werde nicht so
schnell nachgebaut werden können auch
wenn man die nach griechenland bringt
also irgendwie kommt die rechnung nicht
hin ja wobei ging es gibt einerseits
beständen der bundeswehr und bestände
bei der industrie die teilweise noch
modernisiert werden müssen das muss man
auch auseinanderhalten und in beiden
fällen gibt es potenziale bei der
industrie sicherlich deutlich größer als
bei der bundeswehr ich muss aber auch
sagen unsere freiheit unsere sicherheit
die wird gerade in der ukraine
verteidigt und das sollten wir auch
sehen wenn wir in die bestände der
bundeswehr schauen und da sehr
pragmatisch entscheiden was wir jetzt
abgeben können um schnell zu helfen wir
haben die linke argumentiert immer es
war usus dass man nicht in kriegsgebiete
waffen liefert es scheint hier so einen
gemeinsamen konsens zu geben dass eben
die ukraine auch unsere frei verteidigen
wir natürlich alle möglichst alle waffen
liefern sollten ist das eigentlich der
richtige weg hat die linke deutlichen
punkt gefunden der jahrelange deutsche
außenpolitik geprägt hat ich habe die
linke die irrlichter kratzen tatsächlich
auch bei diesem thema gibt es auch ganz
unterschiedliche stimmen gibt auch linke
die tatsächlich inzwischen die
waffenlieferungen befürworten
beispielsweise der ehemalige
außenpolitische sprecher liebig der das
ganz klar befürwortet hier wird aber
klar das dilemma so und eins ist richtig
es ist zu die ukraine schützt auch
unsere freiheit im moment und verteidigt
auch unsere freiheit und deswegen ist es
ein wichtiges anliegen dass die ukraine
unterstützt wird und dass russland nicht
gewinnt weil eins ist auch klar wenn
russland gewinnt dann wird sich russland
überlegen was der nächste schritt ist
aber das rumgeeiere dabei der geschichte
weil er bei den europäern das wird sich
ja wiederholen beim gas und deutschland
sind ganz vorne denn wir sind total
abhängig insofern kann man den ungarn ja
auch ein bisschen verstehen ist völlig
abhängig von diesen öllieferungen also
noch mal machen wir eigentlich genug von
dem was die ukraine dringend bräuchte
wenn man der meinung ist man muss der
ukraine helfen die bundesregierung
arbeitet jeden tag daran und zwar von
der frage der sanktionen bis hin zur
frage der waffenlieferung dinge auf den
weg zu bringen und zu beschleunigen
natürlich ist es ein problem dass wir
uns in den letzten jahren die
vergangenen bundesregierung sich so
blauäugig abhängig gemacht haben von
einem autokraten wie wladimir putin es
ist nicht einfach da ist schnell raus zu
kommen das geht bei kohle und öl
deutlich einfacher als beim gas aber
daran arbeitet robert habeck rund um die
uhr ja und jetzt geht es gleich los und
das wird sicherlich eine muntere debatte
frau bürgerhand vielen dank heute abend
noch einmal verteidigungsausschuss mal
sehen was dann hier am freitag
abgestimmt wird oder ob überhaupt
abgestimmt wird über das sondervermögen
aber es gibt ja noch viele viele andere
politische felder ich glaube nur der ist
dieses sondervermögen auch eine wichtige
rolle in der debatte spielt die
sicherlich gleich friedrich merz
eröffnen wird ich gehe jetzt rein ins
plenum